hi I'm Meghan Camarena also known as
strawburry17 and we're at the Xbox
experience at e3 it's crazy over there
super excited to go over there and play
a Borderlands 3 gears 5 bleeding-edge
they have them all available to demo and
I'm so pumped about it the Xbox
briefings are some of my favorite at e3
but listen up
they had Keanu Reeves for cyberpunk 2077
it doesn't get much better than that not
only is he in the game but he came out
on stage and it was just such a magical
moment for everyone here is really going
to be breathtaking Terry I'm just
talking about it let's go play the games
I gotta concentrate
I just got done playing gear Simon oh my
you're hiding it is terrifying in all
the right ways I'm not gonna be able to
sleep tonight you're gonna die
so I just played Borderlands 3 and it is
absolutely amazing - he did such a good
job at listening to the fans knowing
what they wanted and implementing it
into their new game it plays so smoothly
it's so fun it's packed with a bunch of
new items and I had a great time playing
it good job today
that was incredible fun time hanging out
with me at Xbox experience at e3 I'm
gonna go play some more games